Alright Guardians
Let’s go save the galaxy
Drax sit up! It’s what it’s here for. Drax,
It's called a sofa not a bed. Why’s it so long then?
so enticing.
I'm tired.
What are we doing? I am Groot!
We're not going to talk about that.
I'm hungry.
All right.
Summer begins with their final tour.
That’s why it’s made like this,
just so you lay down on it.
Last night, I had a dream
about when we first met.
This is the end of the road.
Let's make it count.
We are Groot!
I will destroy the guardians.
It's time to say goodbye.
Summer begins.
It's a face off
with their final tour.
I guess we'll die trying.
I am groot.
I know who you are already.
Guardians of the Galaxy.
Volume 3. Are you ready?
I was eight years old when I left
Earth.
Want me to drive now?
I'll drive.
Figure out how to put it in backwards.
I decided die tryin’ ain’t our thing no more.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This will be my new Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 trailer.
Marvel
dropped a whole bunch of new footage
since the last time I did a video.
It's almost like they drop half the movie so
I’ll just break down the biggest stuff.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
The movie's coming out really soon,
so we're doing a giveaway for IMAX tickets
for the movie.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post your favorite moment
from the trailer on the video.
There's so much stuff
going on in this new footage,
probably one of the biggest things,
though, is Nathan Fillion actually making
the final cut of the movie, this time
with his face appearing on screen.
Finally, there's actually a long saga
of Nathan Fillion being
in the Guardians of the Galaxy movies
like being in Marvel movies in general.
Originally,
he was in the first Guardians of the
Galaxy movie
when they were in the kiln in prison.
He was actually playing the voice of this
alien here,
like he wasn't actually on set.
It was a different motion capture act,
and he just did the voice for it.
Shrek Now
I'm going to slather you
up and really go to the ground.
Then when they got to Guardians
of the Galaxy two,
he actually played
a version of Wonder Man,
but it was actually very tongue
in cheek version of the character.
This deleted scene was meant to take place
in the present day Missouri scenes
when they're showing
ego's plan coming to fruition
and he uses all the extra celestial energy
from Star-Lord to activate the seeds
all over the universe.
While this was going
on, there was meant to be a Simon Williams
film festival happening nearby.
James Gunn is from this town in real life.
His real life
parents actually cameoed in this scene.
All the movies that he starred in here,
the posters are meant to be big Easter
eggs for the comics too.
The biggest Easter egg is that he played
Iron Man in a Tony Stark biopic.
The Archon movie poster
is more of a CONAN reference visually, but
Arkane is actually a real Marvel character
from the old school Avengers comics.
Now he's a very CONAN
inspired type of character,
but CONAN himself is actually
a different Marvel character
within the Marvel Comics.
Canon Arkane also inspired
this series of Arnold Schwartz.
BERGER, who's meant to be
an Arnold Schwarzenegger Easter Egg movies
based on the CONAN series,
which the comic book version
of Simon Williams Wonder Man also starred
in the way they portrayed Wonder
Man in the Comics is that his normal alter
ego type of character?
Like when he's just walking around
normally it's Simon Williams
is that he's a Hollywood star,
like he's an actual actor.
So the James Gunn Arkane movie poster is
like an Easter egg within an Easter egg.
Within an Easter egg
for the Wonder Man character.
Dead Before Arrival is a movie
inspired by Christopher Nolan's Inception.
Hacks in Two is a sequel to the fictional
remake of the Jackson movie by Rob Zombie
that appeared in the movie Super,
directed by James Gunn, the toxic Janitor
movie poster, obviously
a reference to the toxic Avenger, directed
by James Gunn's mentor
and frequent collaborator, Lloyd Kaufman.
James Gunn worked for Lloyd
Kaufman at Troma Films.
When he first came to Hollywood,
that was like his first big Hollywood job.
And Lloyd Kaufman also cameos
in the Guardians of the Galaxy films.
The Tribeca movie poster, I think, is
just meant to be a parody of similar
romantic comedies from the early
and mid 2000, maybe also An Easter Egg,
about the big love triangle that Wonder
Man had with Scarlet Witch and Vision.
James Gunn wound up deleting the scene.
But now in Guardians of the Galaxy three,
it looks like he works
for the high evolutionary or whatever base
it is that they're in here, and he's
wearing a very scrotum looking suit.
I think that's the whole joke.
Like it's a giant space looking anus
like a giant celestial butthole
in all the workers here in the background.
Like you can see him holding a gun
or wearing scrotum themed armor
so we can make all the jokes.
When the movie actually comes out,
we find out what's actually going on here.
You can let me know in the comments.
Look, doesn't it not look like
they're all wearing ball sack armor?
One of the other big things here is that
Starhawk is back.
Sylvester Stallone's character sticker
ogre, if you remember, he's actually
the leader of the Guardians 3000 team,
which they debuted during Guardians two.
And that's meant to be Yondu,
his original team, because in the comics
that was the original Guardians team,
and Yondu was on that version
of the comic book team,
the main roster of the Guardians
of the Galaxy in the Marvel movies so far
we've been following
is actually the version of the team
that debuted during Annihilation
when Adam Warlock
actually briefly joined the team,
and obviously they're finally doing
Adam Warlock in the movie.
Now that was a story
where all these characters came together
for the first time,
and also they wore these uniforms
that you see them
wearing during this movie.
There's a couple of new scenes
about a war, like one of him
holding blurb, like the little alien
hybrid that the High Evolutionary created.
He's kind of like Rocket.
There's a couple other really weird
looking, really freakish
looking animal creations in this, too.
I'm assuming this Adam Warlock scene
when he's flying with blurb
like he got the information from blurb
about where
to find the Guardians of the Galaxy
like Blurb told him.
So he just grabbed him
and took him with him.
There's a new scene of Adam Warlock
firing energy from his weapon.
Like his body.
He can actually just give off energy
however he wants to.
This is all based on the annual ax battery
energy that the sovereign were using.
They created him with like
they basically cooked him in a cocoon.
Any baked in that angel lacks
battery energy.
A lot of people confused about what
the batteries are called, too,
because during Guardians of the Galaxy
two, Drax actually called them horrible
eerie batteries, but he was actually
getting the name wrong.
What are they called again?
And he lacks batteries,
artillery, batteries.
That's nothing like what I just said.
That was the whole reason
why the sovereign wanted to kill them
and why they created Adam Warlock
in the first place to go kill them.
So it seems like Adam Warlock tears up
a bunch of nowhere trying to get to them.
My only theory right now
is that at the end of the movie
he will finally turn good
and it'll be a really accelerated version
of his comic book origin story
because James Gunn said
that he was actually playing him
kind of like the way that vision was
when he was first created in Avengers
Age of Ultron.
Sort of like a born yesterday
kind of thing,
where you're this ultra powerful being,
but you basically don't know anything
about what's going on,
like you don't know good from evil.
And that was kind of the vibe of the Adam
Warlock character
when he debuted in the comics
when he was created by the Enclave.
Like, eventually
he decided to choose his own path
and just went around the galaxy
trying to learn about everything.
Initially, he was created by the Enclave
to be a weapon of war.
So it's kind of
what's going on with him in this movie.
Asia created him
to kill the Guardians of the Galaxy.
You actually see her with Adam Warlock
in one of their ships here.
She sends him to kill
the Guardians of the Galaxy.
But I think through those actions, he
winds up learning that they're not so bad.
Maybe he winds up killing one of them.
It would be cool.
Redemption arc for him
if he tried to redeem himself
by joining the next roster
of the Guardians of the Galaxy.
Since James Gunn is coming to DC to do
the new Superman legacy movie in Batman
Braving the boat
all the new rebooted DC movies,
he said that he doesn't know exactly
what Marvel's
going to do with Adam Warlock next.
I'm assuming he will show up somewhere
between Avengers
five Qing Dynasty in Avengers six scores,
but they did say that it's going
to be kind of like Avengers, Infinity War.
In Avengers Endgame, we're like,
not every single character appeared
during Infinity War, but the characters
that were not in Infinity War
all came back. During Endgame.
We see Nebula's new arm weapons.
She actually creates
a couple of different weapons with
it looks like it can just create
whatever weapon
she wants,
like it's creating a blade here.
Then she creates a cannon with it.
We see a couple more groups, new powers,
not every single one of them.
We do know that he can create wings,
but he can grow his fingers
out here in the claws,
like really strong claws.
According to all the licensed toys
there are calling groups, New Chad
formed like the full adult
version of Groot, the Kaiju form of Groot.
But the way that James Gunn explained
the character is that he's meant to be
kind of like the son of the original Groot
from the first movie.
He's not meant to be
the same version of that.
Groot just grown again.
They fight a couple more of the high
evolutionary, freakier looking creations
like the animal human hybrids, and
some of them are just upgraded animals.
This is what looks like a rabbit
with mechanical bug legs, antenna
and giant metal pincers for a mouth.
This has to be some kind of joke
during the movie because it's like this
adorable little bunny
that wouldn't harm a fly
turned into the most fearsome
looking creature you could think of.
But it's like you asked a fourth grader
to make a really freakish looking bunny.
And this is what he came up with.
Like a child would think of something
ridiculous looking like this.
They see another giant one.
The camera's ripping apart.
It looks kind of like a hybrid between
some kind of ape or a gorilla.
A squid like it's got squid arms
in cybernetic torso and legs.
Some of these seem like
the high evolutionary reject experiments,
like things that didn't pan out
because there was a lot of comedy
during Guardians of the Galaxy movies.
I have a feeling they'll be some
kind of jokes about that during the film.
Like some of these creations
just look ridiculous.
Like, did a little kid think of these?
But that's the high evolutionary
whole thing, is that
he just experiments with life,
but they want him to seem
like a douche bag
that hates everything during the movie.
The way the Rocket
explains it in the trailers
is that he
didn't want to actually upgrade things.
He didn't want to make them better.
He just hated the way
that everything was in there.
Just plays into the theme that
everybody is fine the way that they are.
James Gunn actually said that
when Rocket was turned into what he is now
like the walking, talking raccoon,
he'd actually been perfectly happy
to be a regular raccoon.
He didn't want to be upgraded.
There's a funny standoff scene
where you actually see the guardians
of the Galaxy
meeting the new Ravagers
for the first time,
and it seems that
they haven't been back to their ship.
Is the same part of the ship that survived
from Guardians of the Galaxy
to like the Ravagers
larger ship was blown up,
but the small part of it did survive.
And since the events of Avengers Endgame,
this younger
version of Gomora
from 2014 has taken over the Raptors
like she went for
Thanos hardcore boss time on the Ravagers.
I'm guessing Peter Quill just didn't
learn about that because it seems like
when they meet each other,
Peter Quill doesn't know that it's her.
Is in charge of everything and they just
have a funny bro off like standoff moment.
They also have a funny moment later
in the trailer about Gamora
not understanding roots language
because it is the younger
version of Gomora
that didn't get to know Groot over time.
Like the older version of the character.
They have a couple more jokes
about the sofa bed on Counter Earth
with Drax trying to lie like,
why would they call it a sofa bed
if it wasn't going to be a bed?
There's actually a bunch more footage
that they released recently, too.
Most of that stuff
is all behind the scenes.
Featurettes There's a couple new things
in the background,
so I'll probably do a video for that
at some point.
There's just so much Star Wars
stuff happening right now
because we have The Mandalorian Season
three finale.
We also have the Asoka trailer
in all the Star Wars celebration trailers.
Most of the big Marvel series
have just been delayed a little bit.
They're still doing pretty much everything
that you've heard about,
like they're filming Daredevil Born Again
right now.
We actually just found out about Bullseye
coming back to so I'll probably do
a Daredevil bullseye video
at some point this week
since there were so many trailers
that just released.
I did videos for I'll put links
for everything down in the description.
You can click here for my Mandalorian
Season three Episode eight Finale video
and click here for my brand
new Asoka extended trailer with a first
look at Grand Admiral Thrawn
and a bunch of other characters.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.